[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le débat nous
parlerons sécurité ce soir avec cette
question faut-il armée la police
municipale c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement sur la table depuis
janvier 2015 on se rappelle la mort de
cette jeune policière municipale de
montrouge qui avaient été abattus par
amélie coulibaly elle n'était pas armée
ses collègues survivant non plus c'était
seulement 24 heures après les attentats
contre charlie hebdo cette suite
d'événements a été un déclencheur pour
plusieurs communes qui ont décidé
d'armer leurs policiers l ont été
incités en cela par le ministère de
l'intérieur qui avait mises à leur
disposition dès mai 2015 4000 revolver
alors armée la police municipale
permet-il d'assurer la sécurité de ses
agents n'est ce pas paradoxal alors que
certains policiers n'osent pas sortir
leurs armes quel en est le coût et enfin
est ce pertinent face aux menaces
terroristes alors avec nous ce soir pour
en parler jean-luc ourgaud maire adjoint
en charge de la sécurité de montigny le
bretonneux et jean h conseiller
municipal de voisins-le-bretonneux dont
sort messieurs bonsoir jean luc ourgaud
vos policiers vont être équipés de
police de pistolets électriques de type
taser en 2010 est pourquoi cette
décision
dégoûté je crois qu avant de répondre à
votre question il faut resituer le
contexte qui à montigny compte initier
35000 habitants moisséens ses 12000 mon
tennis est une garce 70 mille passagers
par jour montigny c'est un centre
commercial dans lequel il y à des
clients et d'autres personnes donc tout
ceci est en particulier dans les
derniers - dernières années
amené la municipalité à réfléchir à
comment un mieux assurer la sécurité de
ses habitants et mieux protéger les
policiers municipaux et les policiers
électriques sont la solution que vous
avez je leur dis pas que les pistolets
électriques sont la solution mais
puisque le auparavant nous avons d'abord
pris une brigade canine
donc vous voyez qu'il ya plusieurs
plusieurs
possibilités pour assurer une meilleure
sécurité
mais si nous ne souhaitons pas du tout
aller vers le port de revolver de
pistolet armé létale pour reprendre le
terme officiel il nous faut quand même
protéger nos policiers puisque nous
avons une police municipale très
importante sur montigné ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui ça date du précédent maire
et l'évolution malheureusement de la
société nous amènent aujourd'hui à
prendre des dispositions qui permettent
à nos policiers d'intervenir en avec une
meilleure sécurité je dis pas une
sécurité complètement en fait une
meilleure sécurité jean h alors est ce
que les armes ne sont pas un bon moyen
de dissuasion je pense qu'avant de
parler d'armement il faut parler des
missions de la police municipale
l'armement des points d'émission c'est
pas l'armement qui dit l'émission c'est
le point que je voudrais dire or pour
nous la mission essentielle est première
de la police municipale c'est une police
de proximité avec une présence forte
réelle sur le terrain qui établit des
relations de confiance et de qualité
avec la population et avec les jeunes de
façon à faire de la prévention et la
sécurisation notamment dans tout ce qui
touche les déplacements mais est rare
mais ne les empêche pas de continuer à
alors c'est là où je suis pas tout à
fait d'accord parce que l'arm met de la
distance entre la population et l'argent
municipal le policier municipal or ce
que l'on peut par la police de proximité
c'est justement qui n'est pas la moindre
distance entre la population et la
police municipale de ce point de vue là
nous considérons que c'est un mauvais
signal donné et que ça peut faire peur
aux jeunes notamment même une arme de
type intermédiaire d'alors 16h alors
ceci étant dit
je crois qu'il faut d'abord rappeler le
contexte activement vous avez rappelé
montigny voisins ce n'est pas tout à
fait le même cas de figure le res
terroriste existe partout donc à voisins
aussi on va voir gagner mais il ya
beaucoup plus d'incivilités de
comportement absolument inadmissible des
automobilistes que de risque terroriste
je crois qu'il faut le souligner pour
venir à la protection des agents
effectivement à celle qui est mis en
avant la décision prise d'équipé par des
pistolets à impulsion électrique n'est
pas une bonne solution c'est une
solution bancale d'un côté c'est pour
faire plaisir 10 enjambe la police de
l'autre côté je veux pas l'armée
vraiment avec des handicaps à ce que je
crains des bavures n'est ce pas toujours
mieux que rien non parce que le taser
n'est pas l'un c'est une à deux
neutralisations je sais pas si vous
savez ce que c'est sans voix deux
électrodes après 2 millions père 58 vols
ça bloque le système nerveux et la
portée est faible l'un portait n'étaient
que quelques mètres donc si si
l'individu que vous voulez neutralité et
a dit m le taser ne sert à rien il faut
s'assurer que la personne ne soit pas
cardiaque et en plus y ait pu y avoir
des effets indésirables
jean-luc ourgaud un mot là-dessus eux
quel avantage pour vous pour vos
policiers j'ai pas du tout effectivement
la même vision que mon collègue
oui là où je rejoins
la vision de la police municipale la
police municipale c'est une police de
proximité
ça c'est clair mais c'est pas parce que
on arme la police municipale avec des
pistolets électriques que ce n'est plus
une police de proximité parce que les
individus non mais attendez je termine
je t'aime et ne se protègent pas
monsieur à chaque je vous ai pas
interrompu
la population qui n'a rien à se
reprocher elle a pas peur de voir un
policier municipal devant elle avec avec
un pistolet électrique ou autres ce
qu'ils ont à
s'inquiéter c'est effectivement toute
cette frange de population qui est là
pour provoquer pour exciter qui
consomment des produits
licites et là quand ils sont à même 5 6
mètres dit m quand il voit un policier
municipal à quand il verra parce que
pour l'instant ils les ont pas encore
mais ça ne saurait tarder c'est pas pour
obligatoirement leur tirer dessus c'est
pour qu'ils voient qu'ils les policiers
municipaux sont armés et qu' il ferait
mieux d'arrêter leur ainsi visiter
autrement effectivement là on passera
une étape supplémentaire c'est dissuasif
et c'est pas forcément pour tout régler
gendron travail et qui sont
essentiellement quand même des jeunes
plutôt oui c'est vrai tout est jeune je
confirme moi moi moi je considère qu'il
faut mettre contrats des jeunes en
confiance et que donc il faut pas créer
de la distance entre le policier et le
gène et c'est une question de relations
sur le terrain monsieur âgé et non mais
je crois c'est terriblement important et
donc le et en plus je signerai que les
incivilités dont vous parlez n'est même
pas en danger le policier municipal à
bord on veut protéger soi disant le
policier municipal il ne met pas en
danger le temps qui fait aujourd'hui vos
policiers municipaux de tonfa quel genre
quel genre d'armes il a justement occupé
d'aucune arme attaque henry il longe des
gilets pare balles ou extrêmes qui
peuvent effectivement se faire tirer
dessus sans pouvoir se défendre non mais
je pense qu attendait soyons soyons
sérieux il faut sortir du monde de
bisounours mais c'est dans lequel dans
lequel on le questionne journal et vous
voulez vous au niveau de vos amis
politiques et tout dire que tout va bien
poli que bombay alors expliquez-moi
pourquoi le ministre de l'intérieur va
doter la police nationale avec des
véhicules blindés et des policiers qui
auront déjà dernier et je termine si
vous voulez bien et des uniformes qui
seront signés fugier alors gens qui
savent bien c'est de mon évolution de la
situation pardonnez moi votre mère a eu
des discours variées sur cette question
elle a même évoqué de pouvoir équiper
vos policiers
le maire de voisins alexander rosetti
était au départ opposé à la au moment de
la police municipale il ya eu des
pressions il ya eu un certain nombre
d'actions de 2,6 minorité de droite en
fête et à la changer d'avis de façon
bancale comme je disais est à dire l âge
pas choisi d'armes et avec des armes
létales l'a choisi le pistolet à
impulsion électrique soit disant pour
protéger les policiers municipaux c'est
un changement d'attitude mais moi je je
je crois que les petits municipaux
effectivement ce sont des arrive au
niveau de d'une situation de terroristes
mais pas plus que tous les gens qui ont
un uniforme notamment les pompiers
présente pas plus que les élus est-ce
qu'on va s'amuser à re découvrir par
exemple attendait pas plus que les
professeurs ou les directeurs d'école dr
je trouve que l'armement ne répond pas
du tout à la situation et se fait quand
vous parlez du ministère de l'intérieur
vous changez de registre tout vous
parlez de politique de police nationale
non mais je parle de l'évolution de ma
six mois soit je considère que la police
municipale n'a pas à se substituer à
l'appui je suis parfaitement d'accord de
rémission sont parfaitement claires et
messieurs le pendre juste parce que le
temps passe vite chez moi justement vous
parliez de 7 ans sauvagement c'est un
terme qui a été utilisé par un syndicat
policier
aujourd'hui des policiers ont justement
peur d'utiliser leurs armes ça fait
partie de l'actualité qu'est ce que vous
répondez face à cela on cherche à les
armer et en même temps certains parlent
de leur désarroi à ne pas pouvoir sortir
leurs armes bah écoutez je pense que si
si si aujourd'hui première fois dans la
république on a des manifestations de
policiers quasiment tous les jours c'est
bien parce que il ya il ya un problème
entre la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
là on est en train de sortir des glaces
et de la mairie ce mal je pense quand
même que le fait d'armer la police
municipale va amener à s'interroger à
nouveau sur la notion de légitime
défense parce que effectivement avec le
pas avec le pistolet avec le pistolet à
impulsion électrique il y aura que des
crises cardiaques éventuels qui
accompagneront
plus dramatiser non mais ça peut arriver
c'est qu'on sert fort et je sais que ça
peut arriver qu'on sait que ce n'est pas
neutre mais le problème c'est que de ce
fait on va changer la notion de vivid
différence pour toujours atténuer le
rôle négatif entre guillemets de la
personne qui aura tiré et on m'a dit
c'est très dangereux en changent pas
leur jeune âge au niveau policier d'une
salle
micheu cognac eux il faut pas armer la
police municipale d'un côté pour ne pas
les mettre en difficulté quand même
savoir s'ils vont utiliser leurs armes
au pas et de l'autre parce que c'est un
mauvais signal donné à la population
témoin monsieur h moi j'ai pris le temps
d'aller tourner deux nuits avec une
brigade de police municipale et quand
vous avez en face de vous un petit jeune
où le policier municipal vous dit voyez
monsieur hugo celui-là il un casier
judiciaire long comme ça il fait un
doigt d'honneur et la police municipale
ne peut pas intervenir je vis
honnêtement ça pose problème vers l'euro
l'arc de prévention de la police ya des
moyens de certains policiers
effectivement je vous fais remarquer
l'importance de la bretèque à voisins la
situation et 4 qu'il n'y a jamais de
patrouille de nuit mais si les
municipalités
un dernier point avant la fin de cette
émission
ça remet un coup
quel est pour vous l'investissement que
cela représentait bah écoute et un
pistolet à impulsion électrique c'est
3000 euros voilà combien vous en avez
commandé ben on a une vingtaine de on a
vingt policiers municipaux donc voila
vous faites la multiplication mais cette
formation alors plus la formation la
formation ces cinq jours en tout et
ensuite des recyclages une fois par an
parce que il est normal que les agents
j'irai qui ne vont pas utiliser ce
pistolet justement c'est tout ce qui
nous différencie on les dote de ce
pistolet en espérant qu'ils n'auront pas
à s'en servir mais pour qui maintient la
discrétion les usages avec de ce
pistolet un bon niveau en temps entre
guillemets il faut qu'il y ait des cours
de recyclage comme dans n'importe quel
domaine jan 1st derniers mois l'algérie
a mené en concluant les coups d'abord je
fais remarquer que alex auld qui a dit
tout et n'importe quoi aux réunions
internes le 18 octobre elle nous a dit
que c'était 25000 euros par agent et par
armes
à la presse alain donner le montant de
45 mille euros pour l'ensemble de la
police municipale et dans le vie chinois
qui vient de paraître elle donne 25000
euros en fait le trou
puisque effectivement le prix les dollar
mais les mots terre c'est de leur dette
remis leur hausse avec eux que quelques
munitions trois munitions donc c'est
pendant que sa mission et puis la
formation vous avez tout à fait raison
et en fait quand vous regardez le prix
de l'information c'est plutôt de l'ordre
de 28 euros tout compris hors comprise
que quelques milliers
d'autres étaient la joie qui pourraient
investir les wind u160 devient ça si
vous voulez la s'émerveille t on sait
très bien la sécurité en asie et après
on a confirmé à conclure je voudrais
qu'il y avait l'investissement des armes
c'est ma foi c'est un coup 21 fois
supérieur à ce que la commune donne pour
régler des problèmes sociaux individuels
voyage 21 fois ça c'est un autre débat
rêver
comment dit on sait qu'on soit blanc dix
en seconde je pense que malheureusement
la société évolue et qu'on doit on se
doit de protéger nos policiers
municipaux c'est tout et ça ça a un coût
et nous à montigny on l'a su et pas
depuis d'aujourd'hui merci à vous deux
c'est là ça protège police et la fin de
cette édition de 7,8 le débat qui
portait sur l'armement de la police
municipale on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle édition mais
aussi bonne soirée sans leur terrain
[Musique]